welcome rejects to the dark
this is what happens when I have no
idea what the movie is about but I
know the title is underworld good so that
was me under the world yeah yeah I got it
run joxie baby that's right we're back
easy and if you love that then like this
video and come with us to the depths of the
underworld uh this is Kate Beckinsale that's
literally all I came back at sale and lots of
leather from what I understand yeah I leather
I want to see you be leather you don't you don't
then that means I just was out in the sun for
too long and wasn't using the sunblock and it's a
whole different thing do you guys want to what's
a full-length Reaction watch along where you
sync up with your own copy well you can do that
over on patreon that's for the super sexy rejects
they're probably wearing leather they are always
wearing leather that's what all the sexy people
do Greg and John cover several shows over there
exclusively with reaction highlights and watch
alongs included again only in Leather so that's
what you want to see over there leather Daddy's
react I love it leather daddy are you ready for
this I'm so ready I've been waiting 20 years what
20 years I think so I think this came out in 2003.
wow I've only known about this movie for the
last like three years so I've been waiting
three years yeah well let's do it 2003. we're
about to enter the depths of you okay let's go
[Music]
you know you cut a finger on that font now
I see silver I think of Beyonce's tour okay
Beyonce own silver oh vampires don't do well with
silver it's true the war had all but Grand to
a halt in the blink of an eye pollution the most
feared and ruthless leader ever to rule the Lichen
plan had finally been killed it's very Hunchback
sure the Lichen horde scattered to the wind in
a single evening of flame and retribution
oh the like and horde there are werewolves
oh is that what that is yeah Victory it
seemed was in our grasp the very Birthright
of the vampires I saw a little buddha
oh a little bottom the leather cheeks
if he had proved unwilling to follow Lucian
to the Grave though lichens were fewer in
number drippy moist we are here we are well
represented but the moon no longer held her
sway older more powerful lichens were now
able to change at will oh is this black
and white has it evolved but our orders
remained the same it's very dissaturated
because it's badass world and there
aren't much color in badass worlds
if you don't have an angular face you
cannot be in the franchise nope what
your cheekbones look like they got Tim
Burton's casting guy like the weapons of
the previous Century we too would become
obsolete pity because I lived for it I'm
gonna be honest with you I think this is
latex not leather what I've been lied to
oh it's that guy from Gray's Anatomy he's
Meredith's new bay oh baby is he a mixed sweetie
or a mixed and then they were apart but maybe
now together I'm on season like 45 of that show
I got ketchup wow he has not aged
in 20 years he is make hunk vampire
that's Meredith's boo he's doing a lot of good
work for Alzheimer's has he in the show [Laughter]
oh my God that guy Kevin who is that guy
Bloods like the Bloods I don't even want
to say this is just east L.A right now
huh is Kate Beckinsale the prettiest
person to walk the Earth ever
could be because it does feel
that way right now whoa oh [Music]
that was cool yeah whoa so this is blade it's
like blade it's like the Matrix is this also
based on a comic yeah you've never read underworld
I don't know man the comments might be going wild
probably with bar product placement too oh
oh no save the lady I think it's too late
yes snap some pigs sometimes the way
editing is done in these movies makes
me very nauseous does that happen to you
ever in the chase scenes oh [Music] oh
it's cooler and Kate did it she jumped
through the windows cooler sorry guys
oh silver bullets [Music] nice these
effects are pretty good yeah not bad whoa
It's a demo Gordon all right werewolf gang
let's go it's an interesting transformation
do you want to understand what she is yet
I don't think we're supposed to he seems like
a rogue you should touch the silver though
nice Focus rack nice rack focused oh
that was goofy looking but I liked it
what are you talking about that was
so cool oh wait but she does have
her teeth and her eyes Okay so I guess
in this universe silver must not be as
heavy for Vamps or she could be like
a day Walker of some kind she's blade
whoa what are they this is very sin city-esque
not bad would you rather be a vampire or
werewolf oh man I guess probably a vampire
if I had to live as one maybe a vampire
I like werewolf stories a lot though
yeah pan up into a Blood Rave [Music] what
year was live 99 . okay so this is after
oh my God is this like a it's like an underground
werewolf fight yeah like dog fighting between two
werewolves is it oh [Music] oh is it freaking
what's his name is that Michael Sheen yes this
is exactly his name yeah yeah you're running
like a pack of rabid dogs he looks like a pirate
but if you expect to defeat the vampires on
their own ground oh and if you expect to survive
yes Taylor put some clothes on him no I disagree
nah pan down a little bit yeah that is a perfectly
framed Mound God I gotta say I do love beautiful
people I know he looks way better than he does
in those like images I've seen from Twilight I
saw it I don't think I've seen all the Twilights
either I never saw any I've seen Snippets
okay so now she's in with the vamps foreign
I mean they do look like they throw good
parties I would attend even if my blood
got sucked it's definitely any radiated fluid of
some sort ultraviolet ammunition whoa rigel is
dead and Nathaniel could still be out there
we should gather the death dealers and head
back down there and force yes my gut tells me
and I am telling you there could be dozens of
lichens down there who knows maybe more hundreds
we've wanted them to the brink of Extinction
now is the time to get complacent very well
have your man Titan things up I'll have sore
and assembled search team no I want to lead the
team myself absolutely not why it's her gut man
we don't know Soren we don't care about slime
[__] about Soren I hate him already I'd never
dream of treating you like that of course you
would I run along and make sure she's dressed
and ready for the Rivalry for guests Julia
Style's knockoff yeah if you were the real
Julius Styles you would make better choices in
the script and you would dance well I seriously
doubt Victor would want you freezing to death
in here staring at his tomb for hours for hours
no he'd want the death dealers out there right
now scaring every inch of the city I'll never
understand why Victor left him in charge because
he's a hunter he's a bureaucrat not a warrior okay
I'd take it back come on we need to get you
ready the party Amelia's Envoy will be here
any minute who's a millionaire you know Amelia
Bedelia come on didn't you do your research yeah
yeah yes dress
Who costume designer had some
fun with this one yes Queen
of the day definitely wear this one is perfect
that's actually the semi-realistic enhance on
the computer screen it's not like all crazy clear
[Music]
coming still pretty convincing but he's attractive
yes he is for a human who's attractive show me
I'll be the judge of that if you ask me you take
this Warrior business far too seriously you can't
undo the Past movie has some bizarre audio issues
I know do you see this human quite often I can't
be positive but I'm beginning to think the life
ends of blast blast Craven I'm serious I think
they were following him other than food why would
like in stock a human I like this guy is liken
the name for werewolves yeah I didn't know that
lycanthrope oh I heard that before or lycanthropy
Great Scott oh yeah it was so ageist
any progress let's find out
negative
oh no Corvin it was a James T Corbin then here
it says M Corbin this is his brother he's got
a what the what where's Miller what up dude
break out that prison baby you heading home
yeah Nicholas gave me a couple hours off you said
you did a terrific job tonight with the surgery
fun transition
to death dealers voice I know and the candidate
we lost them I feel like this guy
got so much work around this time
it's impossible
wowie the vampires they didn't
realize you were following a human no
uh you don't know that bro when Amelia arrives
to awaken Marcus in just two days time we shall
once again be United as a single coven there's a
lot going on in this movie so far yeah man it's a
whole underworld Society so does Kate want to
protect the humans I don't know like why does
she cares so much about this guy she wants to know
why they're following him yeah what's he got what
what business does he have being embroiled in
the vampire werewolf conflict 3B must be a big
old apartment complex that's how they do it in
some places the apartment used to be a prison
he does his job and then he goes hold that thought
you know where we can find them and try them at
home or you'll have to wait till they catch back
uh oh he's not in some kind of trouble is he
so young here I know he's not in trouble at all
I'm just gonna act real suspicious and lick my
fangs order make people's hair when skin wet
to use olive oil on set a lot of the time yeah
answer the call leave The Matrix
sweet why are they after you [Music]
like an automatic pistol what's your guess as
to why they're after him yeah there's got to
be something to do with his brother maybe
his brother was like a big old lycanthrope
muckety muck working his way up the corporate
lycanthrope ladder you don't think anything
to do with his blood it could be could be
because they're running these tests right
smart God they're like aliens yeah these
are the most interesting looking werewolves
[Laughter] let's go
you got infinite ammo unlocked
sweet would that work
I'm sure in some building it would [Applause]
[Music]
oh
no look at those eyes
so now that he's been bit he's gonna turn what
happens oh he's gonna spit the guy yeah the
blood into the tube right he wanted his blood
it really did make him look monstrous [Music]
I would love to be on set for this moment are we
what are they telling him to do yeah
what is the direction what's going on
I like these weird industrial
music sound flourishes too
bad he is fast not a bad effect [Music]
I already go in the middle [Music]
I feel like he would know enough to know
that you would just stab one of the seats
yeah looking at that camera roll over him
oh no let's go what do you got [Music] okay
land on those feet must be
very good at the trampoline
God they made him look so freaking cool
I heard you 've lost a lot of blood if you don't
stop the car you're gonna get us both killed I'm a
doctor shut up and hold on I'll be fine [Applause]
dude you've got to be smarter than that nice
[Music]
depends on how they Define the rules I guess
you don't like a wet dog it's my favorite smell
I'll get you a candle of that for your birthday
you know how to give a gift I don't know
oh yeah [Music] no I'm a lover loves
shipper ships I want them to hook up
so bad dude mouth to mouth mouth to
mouth mouth to mouth it's not how it
happens anymore but this is 2003. oh he never
even got down give her some of your blood
doctor I am curious what happened to
him between 2003 and Gray's Anatomy I
never saw him if Michael is indeed the
carrier I've tasted his flesh just two
days till full moon soon he will be alike
and he will come looking for us dang I've
tasted his flesh about to upset the
established order it would be hard
if it wasn't so creepy it's hot because it's
creepy oh I didn't get that positive [Music]
I want that purple stuff purple drink purple
drink that is what Lil Wayne was talking about
special werewolf vampire juice
definitely creature of the night little Wayne
wait what's wrong with him oh he's wolfing
what are we watching do you have any idea why
those men were off do you where am I damn it
man answer the question I'm Celine I'm Selena
Kyle the whole house has been absolutely Buzz
oh God you're going to try to turn him
aren't you of course not so why did you
bring him here because he's hot you saved my
life never even told me he wants to see you
this is completely unacceptable I just need you
to understand that Michael is somehow important
to the like oh so now it's Michael would
you just hear me it's just beyond me why
you're still obsessed over this ridiculous
Theory jelly you're infatuated with in my
gym now that's a ridiculous Theory you're so
insecure man he is it's a super unattractive
a bite oh my God you bite him too and then we can
answer the age-old question about what
happens if a vampire bites a werewolf
that's how most women respond to me what is he
gonna do oh yeah he's gonna do a cool guy jump
s
what is that that we keep saying
must be like Hive memories
evening leather top
you brought a werewolf into my house and
now he's an out there wolf check this out oh
go ahead squeeze off murder William Shakespeare
you've copied the Lycan rounds silver nitrate
lethal dose straight into the bloodstream ain't
nothing to dig in like do you hate the wolves in
this I feel bad for them craving been telling more
stories again eh well that's my point it's nothing
but a name I've never underestimated Craven's
luster advancement the Victor believed him and
that's all that matters now where are you going
with this anyway blindly accept this there's got
to be more to Victor picking him and what actually
happened there there's got to be some kind of
conspiracy you were told you were told to set
up shop and lay low a human doesn't concern you
besides I've laid low for quite long enough he's
such a pirate yeah the eyeliner guy liner gotta
get some get some Kia Soul hey you guys could be
brothers don't force me to regret our Arrangement
you just concentrate on your part I've bled for
you once already without me you'd have nothing
uneasy Alliance what is the alliance exactly
this is how we get around in this
universe this is how doors work
I got something chaos magic Wonder
ing what you know like Evil Dead of the scores
of brave souls who entered lucian's Fortress a
single vampire survived Craven but were returning
with evidence of the like and Masters denials
yeah the Branded skin cut from
lucian's very arm that's his skin uh
is his skin why is that his skin because
it's been weathered by time it's just so
thick the thick is our skin it's leather now
you're human he's been marked by a lichen he
knows did Craven put you up to this no
I saw the wound with my own eyes I swear
freaked out and went on the ceiling it was the
whole thing she must know right I've been having
these hallucinations having these delusions
all I know is it feels like my my skull is
splitting in half okay I show a full grown man
bit you feel like I'm skull's on fire but I'm
good Michael are you sure this wasn't a dog
I said it was a man okay it was a man okay it
was a man dog and that woman the woman from
the subway haven't you been listening to me
she took me all right hostage all right
all right and I'm in love with her yes
okay set him up at two Wentworth Miller you
wouldn't have done this to Dominic Purcell [Music]
what do you know man I feel like he
knows more than they're letting on
puzzle
V is for Victor that's good enough for me
oh I can only hope Victor will hear my
plea you've got the juju you're the special
[Music]
it's always the wrist of the Palm man
if this wakes him up though then why
would they ever not be awake you know
it would take a lot of blood probably
they'd have to keep it going constantly
okay organ pumping I believe
that Lucian is Alive and Well
now in this very City during The
Awakening ceremony no she knows too much
whoa super curious what how
she's gonna go about this
is she hiding what's oppressing
Michael Is It Michael is he better
than me do you like him more than
me if you go to him you'll never be
welcome in this house again now that
Victor's awake we'll see what
he has to say about that Boogie
hey uh so I don't know what
she told you but her human
Michael he's not a human at all he's a lichen
come on [Music] oh my God whether you like it
or not you're in the middle of a war that's been
raging for the better part of a thousand years a
blood feud between vampires and lichens werewolves
oh most humans die within an hour
of being bitten by an immortal the
viruses will be transmitted deadly and if
you bit me what I become a vampire instead
how do you know that no one's ever
survived the bike from both species
I track down and kill your kind I am the interest
is finding out why Lucian wants you so badly dude
man bite him he's got different blood create the
combo you must let her come to me we have much to
discuss Celine and I you must not be named is that
he has shown me a great many disturbing things
that will be dealt with soon enough by your
[__] ass what you will do is summon Marcus
oh but he still Slumbers my Lord yeah summon his
ass council members are arriving tomorrow night
to awaken Marcus not you my Lord you've been
awakened a full Century ahead of schedule oh
no is that bill nyhee yeah he kind of looks like
his voice it sounds like yeah like that's a wild
guess but I'm so with you I feel like maybe this
is one of the places we use for interrogations
huh yeah save for the interrogator why do you
hate them so much I've already told you so
you're just following orders good question why do
they hate each other we've gotten nothing so far
thing was in the stable tearing our horses
to pieces I couldn't have saved my mother
or my sister my father died outside trying to
fend them off about to run to my niece's room
oh how did she turn to a vampire though the
war had spilled into our house for days he
drove them off and saved me he turned
me Victor yeah damn that night he made
me a vampire he gave me the strength
to avenge my family I like that yeah
ooh rocking load boys with those special bullets
yeah I get those ultraviolet sunlight rounds I'm
not staying here alone you will if you want
to live no you're not with you likes you
yeah yeah let's go let's go
oh please oh thank goodness
yeah the way she was coming onto him that easily
when the full Moon Rises tomorrow night you
will change he will kill and you will feed it's
unavoidable can't leave you free to roam around
I'm sorry so I'm Gonna Leave You chained to this
table that you'll probably rip out of the floor
single railroad Kelly where the silver should
prevent the transformation at least for a few
hours if I don't return in time do yourself
a favor use it use the favor and yourself
oh she's shook Baba shook as true she just she
did just get to Mac on your boy it was cute
although I feel like he just cheated on Meredith
oh can't have that they were on a little bit of
a break though so we were on a break embarrassed
in Paris in front of everyone he'll go before they
tell them exactly what I tell you to from here on
out you'll do as I say is that in any way unclear
whoa I've been lost without you my Lord be hounded
by Craven in his never-ending oh no he desires the
one thing he cannot have you a tale as old as
time but I did see Lucian I shot him you must
believe me there's been a little complication
the coven is in danger and Michael is the
it's definitely Bill nahi give me
the chance to get the proof fine
ah damn it no these rules these
rules are in place for a good reason
the only reason we have survived this long
the system works you will not be shown an
ounce of leniency when Amelia arrives the council
will convene and decide your fate damn dude that's
cold you have broken the chain and the Covenant
you must be judged now the single tear the single
tier instead out of this now you'll be lucky if
I can convince the console to spare your life
did you have the nerve to cut the skin from
his arm or did illusion to it for you yeah
try to look guiltier man no one opens this door
understood can afford that my future Queen run
off that lichen again you're my future wife she's
pissed she's gonna open the door she wants her
gone because she wants to be his wife yeah and on
to you Julia Stiles no ways Moab thank you yeah
how do I aim this thing foreign
chew your hand off that's a suggestion
change of plans Amelia will be picked up
by Soren and his team that's agile not anymore
you've been reassigned my guy Amelia Bedelia
[Music]
platform nine and three quarters after Dark
oh yes dress oh Dad we're bringing denim in
is that what that is that can't be damn is it
I don't know it had like chiffon over some oh
no it's silk underneath what is that trimming
oh the necklaces everything yeah
I love this costume designer
nice yes Matrix glasses vision
you know when people suspend themselves
through their skin that's like a thing
now yeah that's what that looks like
true that was his Kink when he was alive
why are you helping me I'm not myself yeah I just
want you out of here girl you too good for craving
team up with Celine come on yeah I love that I'm
not I'm helping me we're looking down the Mansion
she's escaped to go to him to Michael I want that
Legend's head on a plate french fried potatoes
we're gonna have a showdown between Michael
and Celine as he's turning there's probably
gonna be something like that but what
about the power of love yeah they'll
think they're fighting but then they'll
realize that they have a common enemy
together
seems like a definite asset always
have a very winding staircase yep
thank you get down get down
what are you a little [__] are you kidding me
jumping would have been
better what you're doing is
there you go werewolf power's kicking in
oh is it the guys from the hospital yeah
I hope she felt like a badass I mean
in this get up you gotta feel like
everything you do is freaking cool
yeah I mean it should have arrived
by now yes I want you to slip off
the property and find out what's
keeping her you've got it I thought you'd
never ask Amelia Bedelia be dead [Music]
gotta get some of that blood give me
that funk that good that nasty stuff
thank you
oh yeah
so the cops on the werewolf team or I don't know
if it's like all cops or if it's just like these
cops yeah I'm just saying do they know he's
turning right now because like are they idiots
yeah they know they are just
idiots no I think they don't know
oh not bad use of CGI
that is a very digital transformation
yeah this ain't gonna go well
he's got different blood yeah
it was a great call by you your
incompetence is becoming most
things that I'm at the core of some ridiculous
conspiracy and here's my proof [Music]
nice now I want you to tell them exactly what
you told me for years we've been
trying to question the bloodlines
oh my God are they gonna answer the question
yeah the key we knew was to locate the rarest
of Bloodlines a direct descendant of Alexander
covinus yes this body was able to change the
disease mold it to its benefit the first straw
immortal he's the special it's a ridiculous
Legend the covina's train itself was hidden
away the genetic code of his human descendants
in its dormant form the sea virus
Through the Ages to Michael Colvin
his blood allows for a perfect
feeling between our species
you're wrong you're living in
the past man one solution has
ejected illusion is dead according to who
according to this [__] Craven
will pay with his life evolution
was I able to get his hands out of the people
and inject it along with Michael's blood yes
yes oh I'm so excited this is all I've ever
wanted Robert I know you kind of said that
at the beginning dude I was really into that
scene I feel like I just blacked out watching
out I was like hanging on his every word he did
a really good job there I need to speak with Khan
Khan the council members have been assassinated
it has begun it has already begun man wow damn
that's a punch the great effect I'm bummed he's
dead because I liked him yeah he's a great
character actor fear not my child absolution
with yours I don't trust him cry for absolution
moment you kill the descendant of corvinus this
damn it I don't trust him all
these old guards got to go I
have to deal
There's No Going Back The Vampires will kill
you on sight for being what you are one of
us one of us one of us but I'm in love with
one of them bringing an end to this conflict
yeah Bill Nye started it I knew it
cool like jittery ghosty effect
so is he in love with her or something but she's
a vampire must be his bae [Music] Sonia red Sonia
damn
I left smart to hide some of that stuff
and all the editing I was born in servitude
yet I hovered them no ill will
even took a vampire for my bride
it was forbidden and they probably
weren't happy about that Victor
feared a blending of the species he killed
her it's an allegory for interracial marriages
[Music] would you like to know Timber and
Victor said I love you like my own daughter yeah
does this mean Craven doesn't suck that's what
I said remember I predicted that earlier dude
good call feel bad now for ribbon on him no
I mean his personality still sucks fair this
movie is low-key very good it's a lot of fun I'd
expect me to some control now that Victor's been
awakened and that is precisely why I need
Michael if Victor was so easy to dispatch
you'd have done it yourself ah you
could have done it while he was sleeping
what whoa what just happened
oh is he gonna Hulk out
hahaha
think about leaving
oh he's got the other bullets now those silver
ones oh dude no what all right take it
back he does suck that was devastating
silver nitrate that you weren't expecting
that dude oh oh this is a mess that was
devastating I really liked him yeah and just
what we found out he's not the actual bad guy
what is she here to do save
Michael yeah they need him
gosh she's so freaking cool
God it must be so dank in here whoa whoa there's
like razor wire or silver whips release the Kraken
it doesn't look too bad no like I love uh
it's Unique it's different looking yeah I
love a practical transformation but two
out of three have been pretty solid in
this movie yeah they're not my favorite but
I think it's cool it's a cool choice anyway
nice dude it's cool swallow the camera right up
oh she got the metallic lipstick yeah I
was just saying that but now it's gone whoa
is that Michael I don't think so it
must be the other guy Victor I mean
uh it must be the solution it must
be this guy the guy with a crazy
deep voice oh yeah yeah the one we just
saw turn come on Kevin Grievous werewolf
dang
I hope they shoot that that Matrix flip
behind you
interesting protagonist for this like she's
a mostly physical character while like everybody
else is arguing about you know Bloodlines and we
heard about her family dying and stuff so she
we have empathy or sympathy for her that's true
that's true yeah we saw that little kiss
oh there will be another yeah for sure
peekaboo
over there
foreign [Music]
my dude yeah Craven God look at all the
chum look at all the bits and body parts
if you're him wouldn't you kind
of be happy to see a wolf though
I guess happier than a vamp although none
happier than to see Kate Beckinsale [Music]
oh Your Gun Works I kill you too just for
helping me I know oh kiss he sees it but
he fell I know it started the war oh no but
why wouldn't Lucian want him to tell her then
she'll be on their team yeah man she deserves to
know especially because Victor turned her like
dang man wow
that was fast
this is my finishing sword that was cool though
to see how strong he is because we heard about it
I wonder if Michael feels akin to them now like
stop killing my kind it's got
to be growing on him at least
[Music] ah damn it man I'll kill him
step in front of him oh the silver no oh that's
fun too they must have had squibs loaded with
silver here come with me I hope I live long enough
to see Victor choke the life from you I bet you
do but let me tell you a little something he's
the one who killed your family I knew it I was
thinking that I was thinking that I should have
said it but I knew it so every once in a while I'm
not engorged himself in human blood I get the
secrets cleaned up the mess knew it that past
he got to you he just couldn't bear the thought
of draining you dry egg you you reminded him so
much of his precious Sonia your place is
by my side we're in love still so be it no
whoa
my man is it dead bite him yes come on yeah let's
see if he can withstand it bite him almost like
he's not looking so good come on he's got one
good eye left oh it tastes like a quarter red
Oh shot you may have killed me
oh my will he's done regardless
so long cuz Okay so Victor does suck
suck I mean uh Craven Victor sucks
yeah they both suck suck in different ways [Music]
nice wire work
nice oh
he's blood though right forgive me
my child it was like it it was you
don't tell him you know whoa
yes whoa I've been waiting for this all my life
because he's a bastard is it not a fair trade
the life I have grown to do that the gift
of immortality now life of your daughter I'd
imagine none of us had a choice in the matter
is he growing wings wings is he a fairy
yeah yes he's going to be very effeminate
after this transformation is done I
loved my daughter but the Abomination
growing in Hawaii was a betrayal of me
and of the Covenant she was pregnant
did what was necessary to protect the species
as I am forced to do yet again
God you guys in your pure blood
dang dude
for a second I thought he was gonna
have bat wings how'd he get down there
whoa so how's he doing that he's got
like super Supernatural Speed and Agility
as an angry like Empire
[Laughter]
that stunt looked a little wiry
Bill Knight he's thrown down these stunts boy
so dank
Come On Celine jump in there I think
she would just get a hurt right [Music]
no no
come on mcliken yeah okay yeah
it's gotta do what's right oh folks
that's your own daughter might as well be
[Applause]
what's gonna happen you know Victor's gonna
kill him and then they're gonna you know
Stave off the hybrid race forever
and uh we're all gonna go home whoa
very graceful 9.8 get him [Applause] no
keep expecting his head to slide off
[Music]
whoa [Music]
well that is not what I thought happened gnarly
soups Gnar also she was able to kill him now tame
the Beast Michael looks like an avatar yeah
a little bit it's a crispy Avatar come on
who is it what are they hearing oh and they
will have all seen her fight on their behalf
their king queen of the underworld
baby yeah sock face suck face suck
face suck face not blood I'm bummed
that Lucian died I know I loved him
is he back to normal [Music] yup yup yup I'm in
place it around his neck let's go let's go Oh no
you're going the wrong way honey grab her grab
her what I'm just gonna follow you nude all this
meanwhile back at home yo what's
happening Marcus yeah wake him up
let him out let him out yeah the consequences
of this night will reverberate through the
holes of both great Caverns for many years
of course through all the sequels to come
Marcus will take the throne the tide of anger
and retribution will spill out into the night
differences will be set aside oh boy
and soon I will become the hunted no
[Music] no who's waking Marcus Amelia's
dad well there's that guy Bleeding Out
damn so does that mean what right
what Kevin Grievous yeah I think that's how you
say it he had a story credit as well I think he
he worked on like Frankenstein cried he wrote this
movie that's so wild to me I didn't realize I mean
you know like it was like a surprise when they did
Halloween 2019 or whatever that was or no that's
way too reason 2017. when they do the Blum House
Halloween and Danny McBride co-wrote it everyone
was like what I had no idea if it is the same
Danny McBride that's a wild thing I mean is there
more than one Danny McBride not that I know of
in Hollywood but I'm just like it's such a common
sounding name that I gotta imagine damn oh Scotty
Scott Speedman there you go that's his name don't
wear it out well and was uh was Kate Beckinsale
married to Len Wiseman when this happened I don't
know who that is he's the director oh and this
is one of those like that's how they met maybe
what else did he Direct you know various action
stuff that I don't remember well enough to name
off can I tell you something no we're not
here to discuss anything JK what did you
want to tell me I really [__] with that movie
really yeah can I tell you something even worse
sure I preferred that to Blade wow shots fired
I really like blade I love blade but so no shots
fired at Blaine I just thought this was awesome
this was really scary we enjoyed that I think that
there were a lot of twists and turns I feel like
Kate Beckinsale really held it down then there was
like just when you think you've got it it wasn't
too many twos and turns but I was like oh snap
that's smart that's cool I loved the costume
design in this I love the set design I think
that it was everything that one of these movies in
the early 2000s should be I feel like that holds
up really well um I was super into that movie
yeah yeah I don't know if I would necessarily
put it above blade for me but for what I think
anybody would but me but I do it's all good no
I'm like I'm excited that's awesome and yeah like
this is another one of those movies that like I
remember the moment in time when it was first
coming out I remember people talking about it
um but yeah this has that sort of perfectly
satisfying like it's a little bit cheesy at times
but in a way that I appreciated I've had fun with
I was never not having fun and enjoying myself and
as a fan of both these kinds of lore and then you
know combining them at you know in that Matrix era
where it is like let's get leather and sunglasses
and latex and Industrial music together and all
that stuff like yeah this was a very satisfying
concoction and this felt like I don't know if this
is actually inspired by a comic book or something
like that but it definitely felt like it and and
Kevin Grievous the the deep voice Guy having a
story by credit I wonder if maybe it's even based
off of some kind of graphic novel he was right
oh but uh but yeah it was based off his life
that's what I was thinking I feel like this
gave us both exactly what we wanted though
early on you jumped on I I've always wanted to
see what happened the vampire and the Werewolf
together could it work and I was like lover of
Love shippers and it gave us both what we were
we're looking for like yeah I think that's what
honestly a lot of movies as you know are missing
for me I need a I need a love story sure and
this had that and not just with them but with
the Sonia and uh Lucian one I feel like that was
a really cool element that they brought in and
and like you said obviously it's an allegory for
things but I do love Forbidden Love and why and
then like that carrying down generations and I
also love you know when you look at your parents
one way and you think they're who you think
they are and then things shift and then all
of a sudden the way she was looking at Victor her
whole world changed and I I just thought that was
bad yeah well it's got that quality where like
it is very much of the time it came out but also
like what the story is is this sort of Timeless
thing yeah where it is about you know legacies
and deceits spread out over generations and stuff
like that and and yeah these like feuds that rage
on throughout history and people who you know
are involved with them but who don't really
know where they came from like yeah it's it's got
that quality where you're like oh this you could
easily apply this to like interracial romance or
something like that as like an allegorical thing
um you know so it's like kind of neat that a
movie like this would have some kind of different
classes or you know yeah yeah just the mixing of
different stations or classes or or whatever it
might be and so it's just like a nugget of like
true life applicability that I wasn't expecting
here and also when you come up thinking that
you're on the right side of something and then
you're not right like you you only know what you
know and until you know more yeah and I thought it
was interesting the way that they orchestrated
this because you know it's like Celine is is
ostensibly your main character and certainly like
we we learn obviously what her backstory is but
like it's an interestingly told movie because
you learn so much about like the lore and the
situation and the conflicts between these other
characters and I feel like she at the heart of
it is kind of an interesting like audience Cipher
almost because you're not like really intimately
getting to know her like you're not really close
to her very much you kept you said that a couple
times but I didn't feel that way because we knew
the story of her parents we knew we knew that uh
Victor was like surrogate dad and we knew Craven
wanted to be with her and and she was fighting
against that like I thought I felt like we had a
good grip on what her relationships were what her
goals were what kind of human person or vampire
she was what her values were who she wanted
to help and um yeah I thought that like I it's
not like we had a lot of sit Downs with her over
coffee where it was like what are your aspirations
in this world but I did feel like they did give us
enough for me to give a [__] about her yeah
and I think too it's cool that she does very
convincingly because of all these different things
we're talking about she manages to feel naturally
like a figure alone at the center and between
all these things but not truly especially when
she discovers you know like the true nature of of
what the vampires have done over time like yeah
she she does feel like this figure who's dislodged
from both Clans you know and is able to be this
kind of an island yeah and and that seems like a
fun Prospect for sequels to come and whatnot and
even though you don't have like a fully fledged
romance here between her and Michael like I liked
the hinting they did with that and uh or you know
at least just like the breach of possibility yeah
um and it gets twice they did it because two times
I wanted them to kiss one more time at the end I
know well and that's that's the thing too is I'm
excited you know if we ever get to see more of
these like um which will happen if you like the
videos friends video recommended to them but uh
but yeah like it seems it's just like a really fun
uh take and I'm sure we've seen a bunch of things
now that have uh you know capitalized on a movie
like this and sort of taken the ball and run with
it um but yeah it's like I I'm excited to see what
this lore can grow into because that's as a horror
that's always been a thing of I liked it on Amazon
here it says the genres are suspense fantasy
atmospheric and biting there's a lot of biting
but yeah it's like I I love the idea that we're
finally seeing that you know what happens when
you combine the two you know infections the two
Supernatural diseases the two Bloodlines together
um and you know what the two of them could become
as this sort of third group that exists in between
them almost if they're able to find people who you
know are sympathetic or whatever and I like that
too I like the the disposition of like they really
kind of give you this convincing portrayal where
you think okay the vampires are the good-ish guys
I guess and when Bill Nye First shows up you're
like okay like you know I'm this does seem like
somebody who can help who who can provide us
a little bit of Hope for Celine and whatnot
and then and then when the Betrayal comes down
and you find out the truth you're like damn I
do kind of feel for her position yeah now and
so it's cool to kind of watch a movie that can
sell you this main character on One mission that
you're sort of on board for and then it you know
pulls the rug and goes oh wait the thing we've
been doing is kind of the wrong Mission all along
and it's built off of deceits and whatnot lies
yeah uh also you pointed out what it said here
about suspense fantasy atmospheric and biting it
also says a beautiful vampire caught up in age
old battle falls in love with one of her enemies
what I like about this is that it actually wasn't
really that she didn't fall in love with one of
her enemies like she didn't fall in love with a
wolf yeah she went to protect a human because she
was curious what was happening I think that was a
stronger Choice than her just falling in love with
a Vampire I mean her falling in love with a wolf
because we've seen things like that throughout
the ages yeah I thought that this was different
because they both sides wanted something from
him there was stuff going on on both sides and
I I really did enjoy that what did you feel about
the run time that little over two hour run time
usually these movies are slightly shorter than
that I find was it did it drag for you at all
um no not not hugely I mean there were times there
are moments where I feel like they're I maybe
expected like a bit more stylization with certain
things like if you're comparing pound for pound
I feel like blade has slightly more like in terms
of camera like slightly more stylish action maybe
um I agree with that fluid
in that department but uh
I don't know I mean this is this is kind of the
vibe I was certainly expecting the tone and yeah
it's it's uh it's a fun fantasy world that has
yeah like the right kind of cheese so it wasn't
really dragging there are moments where it does
feel a little predictable or whatever or or you
know like the vampires in certain cases are so
true to character as this movie draws them that
you can see certain things coming or they'll
behave you know with such Hubris in certain
moments that you're like ah right I can see what's
about to happen but in a way that never like
uh never took away from the experience for me yeah
I'm with you on that uh Kate Beckinsale to me when
you think of her like this is what she's known
for the most right I guess so isn't that kind
of weird like put her on the map not to uh call
you out or put you on the spot but like what are
other Kate Beckinsale famous roles I know she's
in The Aviator she plays Ava Gardner like I know
she's on social media playing with her cats is
that what she does right I see that all the time
like this is this was this what put her on the map
initially I feel like it was yeah yeah and housing
oh yeah I remember Van Helsing too but yeah I mean
like this is her this is her franchise I know and
I wonder if they'll revive it again at some point
I mean there was one in 2016. so it seems like one
of the more reliable aspects of her career yeah
wow there was one in 2016 how many have there been
four or five Pearl Harbor that certainly would
have also done yeah yeah it was Pearl Harbor
before this yeah two years okay also it's a
different Danny McBride from what I gather
it's not the same day okay so what else has he
done a lot of Underworld he's like the shepherd
I mean you and I were both he's done a whole bunch
of Underworld and he did Fallen Angel oh no Fallen
Angel was short different following yeah huh yeah
interesting okay I'm glad that you clarified that
because I'm sure in the comments people were gonna
be like different it's not that Danny McBride that
would have been wild yeah can you tell me what
the director has done Lynn Wiseman yeah I know
he's done you said they they were married I think
so it's still weird I think they got divorced
eventually give me that tea give me that gossip
lover of Love shippers ships oh Total Recall I
know he's a producer on that yeah oh he was the
EP on Swamp Thing remake that's wild yeah okay all
right let's see director what you got something TV
series Sleepy Hollow TV series Total Recall remake
yeah I mean underworld is certainly his like big
claim to fame and uh and yeah I mean I could I
could see how this would have launched him I
mean like you know this didn't have like the
most directorial voice where I'm like damn gotta
see more of what this specific director does
um but I liked a lot of the production designs
and I liked a lot of you know the the tone and the
pace and stuff like that it has an appropriately
dreary kind of again Matrix you know hodgepodge
Vibe where it's yeah rain and leather and coats
I thought he had a good sense of his characters
as a director though like I agree with you that it
was I felt like this was as stylized as blade in
terms of set design and costumes but not in terms
of cinematography um necessarily but I do feel
like he I don't know he seemed like an actor's
director I obviously wasn't on set but I thought
there was some really solid performances I knew
where I stood with everybody yeah I really dug
this I really dug this I'm glad man I hope that
we watch more of these likewise like this yeah
likewise like this yeah this is to me had sort
of almost like a midnight movie quality but in a
in a good way like I felt like I was watching a b
movie but in a way that I you know was was always
like a fun kind of a b move I kind of expect it to
feel that way going into this so maybe that's why
I was surprised like I I don't know I feel like
this is a really good movie sure I know I really
enjoyed it I guess I I probably from the outside
expected something that was a bit more slick like
this wasn't quite as slick as I expected it had
all like the designs and all the production values
of something I expected but it wasn't quite as
like ooh kinetic crazy again like a lot of the
look and the and then and like the visual Flair
wasn't exactly what I expected and and it's in a
way where it wasn't overly overdone you know it
was less kind of stylized then in a way that's
less distracting you could argue so yeah we have
to watch more so that we can see what happened to
Julia Stiles yeah oh and she did a good job too I
mean like yeah I liked there were certain I like
the Craven character I was like this like you
know he was always uh him again this dude yeah
yeah yeah just the kind of character where I'm
like man even when I think you're kind of on our
side I don't really like you that much and and not
in like uh oh it's taking away from the movie but
just yeah like just like ah totally just seemed
like that kind of character who's like even when
you're on the right side you're just like you're
on my nerves but I understood his motivation yeah
yeah it was cool yeah and I like the murkiness
of that of like okay so maybe he's helping Lucian
out okay well sort of but not really he's all
self-serving in the end you're all looking out
for themselves yeah yeah totally so like I liked
I think my favorite aspects are just like the
way the conflict is drawn and the way that that
affects the characters I think that was the most
interesting element and and like Michael Sheen man
killing it Bill Nighy great as well uh why are you
helping me am I helping you I'm helping me yeah
I'm helping me that's right I'm gonna start are
you telling me the people that you liked I just
love the line yeah Michael Sheen anybody else
that really stood out for you uh I mean I liked
your boy I thought he did a fine Jaime mostly he
just kind of has to be in agony and and you know
buff Wentworth Miller not in too much of it no no
yeah this is probably on the come up for him but
it was nice yeah nice to see him you know and uh
and yeah it's uh I I'm excited hopefully to see
more of Celine I feel like there's a a lot of
potential for her to grow in this role and to you
know continue making it her own because she's got
so many she's like when she steps on screen
she's just so badass it kind of reminded me
of like me you uh Jessica Beale and like Blade
Trinity but but this is better than that yeah
um I mean Jessica Biel is great in that movie
wasted you know in that movie as so many of the
good parts of that movie were but uh but yeah
this gave me kind of kind of that Vibe yeah I
feel you I I definitely feel you on that any final
thoughts on underworld no is a good time man I'm
glad we saw it I'm glad you enjoyed it as much I
I didn't quite enjoy it as much as you but this
was still a lot of fun and yeah for me again as
a fan of werewolves vampires uh cyberpunk uh and
the question of what happens when you combine the
two um I mean and that's that's maybe one thing is
uh as like I can easily forgive like yeah you know
it's it's it's the 2000s We're not gonna do like a
Rick Baker practical werewolf transformation yeah
and I liked the Abomination the the hybrid design
but part of me was like oh man I wish this was a
little more like he kind of looked mostly like a
super werewolf or it's like I wanted slightly more
bat-like features maybe from that you wanted wings
and you didn't get wings get my wings my big old
pointy ears well when we're done with this you
can go get some wings yeah Buffalo Barbecue lemon
pepper whatever you want what does that mean I've
been working for 10 hours and all I want is wig
stop I don't know but I definitely like it there
you're gonna so you liking their liking there
who do we like in the most today who do we like
we like Danny pancakes all right because Danny
knows why I wrote this but it's not the Danny
McBride it sounds like a little disappointing but
you know it's not disappointing you hear Danny
pancakes and you're like breakfast is served I
just want to slather you in some syrup my dude
I just wanna a little whipped cream yeah some
chocolate chips yeah ooh banana let me ask you
this uh and you have to answer honestly even
though it's Danny pancakes waffles or pancakes
oh dude it depends on the day okay mine's always
pancakes and that's why Danny's my guy pancakes
it's always pancakes waffles are good but they're
not Danny pancakes they're not Danny pancakes no
you don't want to you don't want to start your
day off with anything other than Danny pancakes
all right no it's my first time in the morning
last stop before I go to sleep is waking up
next morning to some more Danny pancakes Danny
puts that D on the paint like the D on the p
[Music] and that's how we know we love Danny
pancakes thanks for being a super sexy thanks
for being sexy Danny P baby you must wear a lot of
leather oh definitely yeah he's watching this in
a full latex jumpsuit right now four set coat you
know sunglasses chokers knee-highs earrings boots
all of it oh I like their their cool like silver
nitrate and like UV bullets too that was cool that
was cool we should get different types of bullets
and Technology whatever they were creating I was
like oh yeah it was good Danny's got the syrup
bullets though oh I would I would take a certain
bullet I would I would take a short roll if you
went to like a breakfast bar and they were like
Circle I believe load it up yeah fire away they're
gonna go to Benihana and they put the oil in the
squeeze can syrup me anyway let's get out of here
yes or I say something weird thanks for joining
us for underworld well we appreciate that what's
this it's a heart that I'm also looking through
Oh I thought you were doing some nighttime vision
uh thank you for going Danny's pancakes wait I'm
about to make a good pun thank you for going over
underworld with us because over the opposite under
like the video so that we can watch more
of this I really like this one and would
love to see some more with you guys
do it let's go on a journey okay later